one looking into a puddle sees dirt in
it
the other
Stars reflected in it
an evil person cannot be happy
for being alone with himself
he remains alone with the villain
death is most afraid of those people
whose life has the greatest value
Act only according to that Maxim
by which you can at the same time
that it should become a universal law
give a person everything that he desires
and at the same moment you will feel
that this is not everything
if you punish a child for what is bad
and reward for what is good
then he will do good for the sake of
profit
the busier we are the more acutely we
feel that we live
the more conscious we are of life
out of the Crooked Timber of humanity
no straight thing was ever made
the freedom to wave your arms
ends at the tip of the other person's
nose
character is the ability to act
according to principles
if a man makes himself a worm
he must not complain when he is trodden
on
do not treat others as a way to achieve
your own goals
Whoever has given up excesses has gotten
rid of hardships
sometimes we have to deny knowledge in
order to make room for faith
a person rarely thinks about darkness
and the light
about trouble and happiness
and contentment
about suffering and conversely
always thinks about light in the
Darkness
about happiness in the trouble
about prosperity in poverty
the reading of all good books is like a
conversation with the finest minds of
past centuries
women make even the men more
sophisticated
have the courage to use your own mind
think your own thoughts and live your
own life
all the interests of my reason
speculative as well as practical
combined in the three following
questions
one
can I know
two what ought I to do
three
what may I hope
man is the only being who needs
education
we are not rich by what we possess
but by what we can do without
Only He Who himself enlightened is not
afraid of Shadows
all our knowledge begins with the senses
proceeds then to the understanding
and ends with reason
there is nothing higher than reason
dare to think
have the courage to use your own
intelligence
marriage is the union of two people of
different Sexes with a view to the
mutual possession of each other's sexual
attributes
for the duration of their lives
the death of Dogma is the birth of
reality
rules for happiness
something to do someone to love
something to hope for
a cheerful expression on the face will
gradually be reflected in the inner
world
smile
the ability to ask reasonable questions
is a sign of intelligence and
discernment
happiness is not an ideal of reason
but of imagination
experience without theory is blind
but Theory without experience is mere
intellectual play
a person can become a person only
through education
every person is what education made him
humanity is the ability to participate
in the fate of other people
the destiny of a woman is to rule
the destiny of a man is to reign
because passion rules and the mind
Reigns
it is not thoughts that need to be
taught
but thinking
the more habits the less freedom
the life of people devoted only to
pleasure without a reason
and without morality has no value
a man is jealous when he loves
a woman even when she does not love
because the admirer is won by other
women disappear from the circle of her
admirers
what is beautiful is what you like
regardless of the meaning
science is organized knowledge
wisdom is an organized life
you should not fear being refuted
you should fear something else
to be incomprehensible
he who fearfully cares about how not to
lose his life
will never rejoice in this life
children should be brought up not for
the present
but for the future
perhaps a better state of the family
genius is the ability to independently
arrive at and understand Concepts
that would normally have to be taught by
another person
space and time are the framework within
which the mind is constrained to
construct its experience of reality
thoughts without content are empty
intuitions without concepts are blind
man must be disciplined
for he is by nature raw and Wild
there is something Splendid about
innocence
but what is bad about it in turn
is that it cannot protect itself very
well and is easily seduced
Enlightenment is man's emergence from
his self-incurred immaturity
nothing is divine but what is agreeable
to reason
he who is cruel to animals becomes hard
also in his dealings with men
we can judge the heart of a man by his
treatment of animals
without man and his potential for moral
progress
the whole of reality would be a mere
wilderness
a thing in vain
and have no final purpose
two things fill my mind with ever
increasing wonder and awe
the more often and the more intensely
the reflection dwells on them
The Starry heavens above me
and the moral law Within Me
a wise man can change his mind
a fool never
only the descent into the hell of
self-knowledge can pave the way to
Godliness
in action
to have moral worth must be done from
Duty
to be is to do
if you still have a desire for sex after
it means that there is still so much
life left to be lived
simply two acquiesce and skepticism can
never suffice to overcome the
restlessness of reason
for peace to Reign on Earth
humans must evolve into new beings who
have learned to see the whole first
morality is not the doctrine of how we
may make ourselves happy
but how we make ourselves worthy of
happiness
Beauty presents an indeterminate concept
of understanding
the sublime in indeterminate concept of
reason